- Today on this episode of Bottom Gear.
- I'm a bit lost right now.
- Ow, ow, ow.
- How am I always breaking everything?
- Oh, shit.
(upbeat techno music)
- Hello and welcome to
another very special episode
of Trash Taste Outside.
- Trash Taste Outside.
(everyone cheers)
- So, what are we doing today, boys?
- [Connor] Today, we will
be going to Hiroshima,
to do the Shimanami Kaido Cycling route,
which is 75 kilometers long.
And we'll be doing
challenges along the way
to see who is the victor.
- [Joey] So basically the Shimanami Kaido
is this beautiful cycling road
that connects Hiroshima
Prefecture to Ehime Prefecture.
And is this beautiful
island hopping experience.
- [Connor] Along the
way, there is a blue line
on the floor that goes from the start
to the finish along the whole road
so you know exactly where to go.
Anyone can rent a bike for less than $15.
So, it's super beginner friendly,
and anyone can do this, but it is long.
And we will see who will
die, who will make it,
and who will be gone.
- Probably me.
(Connor laughs)
Let's get to the video.
Cycling 75 kilometers in one day.
I'm sure to some, this may
sound like a walk in the park,
but for the three of us,
there were definitely some
mixed feelings about it.
- Hello.
(Connor chuckles)
It is the day before,
specifically, 30 minutes
before the next day I leave.
- Technically speaking,
I should have an advantage
over the other two boys,
considering that I've gone
across like 150 kilometers
on Journey Across Japan,
which is a thing I did like two years ago.
And because I did do it two years ago,
and I haven't been cycling since then,
I'm basically just gone
back to square one.
- I'm a fucking frail-ass nerd, okay?
All I know is how to
sit on my fucking couch
and sit in front of my fucking computer
and watch an animes and
talk about anime titties.
And now I'm being asked to cycle
like a hundred fucking
kilometers in a day.
Are you kidding me?
- It's going to be hard.
(Connor chuckles)
I just don't want it to be cold.
- So I feel like I'm
definitely going to be
on the mid range.
Like, Connor is definitely
more fit than I am,
but I'm most likely more fit than Garnt.
So, yeah, basically I'm
probably going to have
the most boring point of view.
(Joey chuckles)
The most average point of view of this.
- I've never, like, run a marathon.
I've never been involved in many,
like, physical activities
that are this hard.
I'm not trying to set
expectations low or anything,
but if I just end up
completing the course,
I'm going to be happy with myself.
- I'm probably going to win.
I'm not just saying that for the meme,
because I always say that I'm going win,
but I genuinely think this
time I'm going to win.
I've prepared. I have
brought the right clothing.
I am ready to get this fat W,
and I'm the fittest
out of the three of us.
Joey, has only been to the gym like once
in like, the past two months.
This man doesn't run, he's going to die.
- Connor's probably
hyping himself up again.
And as he should.
Not to jinx anything with the
antagonist card or anything,
but he needs a fucking W, man.
If he loses one more time,
might as well change his job
title to professional L taker.
- [Connor] So we packed our bags
and flew all the way to Hiroshima.
And once again, the night before,
we were feeling fine, absolutely fine.
- Gentlemen, we are doing
our second, I guess,
official special or like
special we planned out before.
How are you boys feeling?
- Just tired.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm tired and I haven't
even done anything yet technically.
- You know what?
I am fucking exhausted today.
- Yeah.
- And I have a whole fucking eight hours
of cycling tomorrow and I've got to say,
- What do you mean you?
We all have eight hours
of cycling tomorrow.
(Garnt laughs)
- I got to say,
I don't how you boys have
been feeling about this,
I am not looking forward to this.
- I mean, we've known
about this for, like, what?
Maybe a month or so?
So I figured, you know,
this is the end of October now, right?
And I was like, All right,
I have all of October to
go to the gym, train up.
(Garnt laughs)
And October just happened to be
the busiest month of this year.
So I think I went once this month.
- Yeah.
- And then I was like,
All right, if I can't go to the gym,
I can at least eat healthy.
I ate like absolute garbage.
(both laugh)
- So you're probably be
the one who quits, then.
- So yeah, I basically, like,
de buffed myself like crazy.
- I'm feeling okay about it.
- I mean, you are the fittest
out of the three of us.
- Yeah.
- I guess.
- Physically.
- Technically.
- You think I love
doing physical exercise?
I hate physical exercise.
You know, fucking Drifting Special,
I'm in a chair all day, I could die.
I don't give a fuck, that's easy work.
- What is the longest you've ever cycled?
- I don't even know.
(Garnt laughs)
I have never cycled,
- From my house to the convenience store.
- I have never cycled long distance,
I've never run long distance,
I've never exerted myself for
like a long period of time.
I'm just going to try and survive.
- I mean, look, to be fair,
you've won enough times
on a special, okay?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's time for the winner to change.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- So, didn't you guys
all buy clothes for this?
I told the guys, I was like,
two days before I'm like,
"Guys, Amazon only delivers tomorrow."
"This is your last day to buy things."
We didn't get to try on the stuff.
So we've all bought stuff.
Do you guys want to show off
your clothes that you have?
- I haven't tried it
on yet, but we'll see.
- Yeah, I'll just try
mine on, I'll get mine on.
- All right, let's try it.
- [Garnt] All right, we're ready.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- You look like a gimp.
- Have you read the One-Punch Man manga?
There's like a character that's,
- Gara, right?
- Sperm character,
(everyone laughs)
I am the sperm. It's got
like padding as well here.
- Let me see that ass.
- [Joey] Oh nice. It is
like a cheap cosplay suit.
- Oh God, yeah, I know.
- This is so comfortable though.
Actually, why don't all
pants have this built in?
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- My God, all right, well, nice.
What do you think, boys, good?
- Those are some really hard
nipples, you've got there, man.
- I always have stiff nips.
Always, no matter what.
- Yours are going to be chaffing.
- We're going to get demonetized for that.
(all laugh)
- Whenever you're ready,
Joey, whenever you're ready.
(Garnt laughs)
- You look like every
80-year-old Japanese man
I see cycling.
- You look like you've
got a diver's suit on.
- Look at this man's camel toe.
- Oh my God.
- You like?
- We're going to get so
demonetized, Jesus Christ.
- Get tea bag from this.
- You are really covered up,
dude. Can your balls breathe?
They look like,
- It's a little tight. And
this is an L size, too.
- Can't stop staring, now that you,
- Just don't look at the
dick. Don't look at the dick.
- Oh God.
- I'm turning into Pink Guy.
(Garnt laughs)
- Knowing Garnt, he probably fucked up
and bought something in
the completely wrong size.
That's a 100% a Garnt move.
(Joey laughs)
- Guys, I've made a massive,
(all laugh)
- [Connor] Oh my God. How tight is that?
- I bought size M. It's Japanese size M.
This is so tight.
- Why would you buy M size?
- Because I'm only M size,
- You're like one step away from T-posing.
- Oh my God.
- Your dick is being destroyed
in that, Garnt. Holy fuck.
- I'm going to have to
cycle eight hours in this?
(Joey laughs)
- [Connor] You know
- Oh my God.
- I may be monkey brained,
but I didn't do monkey brain
with the clothes shopping.
- Wait, do you not have like
padding, like underneath?
- No, no.
- Oh, well.
Boys, I did get a little gift
because I knew that
you boys would fuck up.
I bought pants with padding in them
because I just had a feeling
that you both would just not
realize you should probably,
- I mean, I'm not as monkey
brained as this fellow.
- You know, did Chris buy yours?
- No, I bought mine.
- Oh, okay. Fair enough.
- What do you take me for?
- I've got you one, Garnt.
So, I'm a nice friend.
- Here you go.
- [Connor] I bought gifts
just in case they forgot.
So that's pants for you. XL, Garnt.
Do they go on?
Oh my God. It's almost like they fit.
Look at that. What a good friend,
- I can't feel these at all.
Like, I cannot feel these at all.
(Connor laughing)
- You look like your wearing a diaper
(Joey laughs)
- Oh my God. Are you
ready for tomorrow, Garnt?
- I am not ready for tomorrow.
- I feel like I have
the perfect set up here.
- I'm dreading this
more than I already was.
And I feel like a fucking idiot now.
I feel like Connor, now.
This is what you do on
your channel, Connor.
I just talk about anime things,
I'm in Disembodied Voice.
What the fuck am I doing?
- The only thing that's dreaded
more for tomorrow than you
is your nuts.
(All laughing)
Your nuts are in a fucking
Vise-Grip right now.
- Bro, you should text Sydney
and let her know you're
not going to be able
to have kids anymore.
Like that's off the table.
- [Joey] This is live footage
of Garnt's future children dying.
- I'm just going to leave now, man.
This has been the sperm men, I guess.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
We're going to be cycling tomorrow.
- So, we're going to go to the Onsen now
because this is a Ryokan.
So we're going to go relax before tomorrow
before we start the
horrible, horrible task.
All right, bye.
(upbeat music)
- It is 8:05 in the morning,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's a beautiful morning in
Onomichi, Hiroshima today.
- Wow
- And we are,
I sound like a weather reporter.
(all laughing)
It's a beautiful day
in Onomichi, Hiroshima.
- It's a beautiful day here.
- We wanted to start at seven, it is now,
- 8:05.
- 8:05, a little late.
Hoping that won't come
to bite us in the ass.
- I just realized I was like
looking at an imaginary watch.
It's like, yes, it is also 8:05,
I can concur with you guys.
- So, right behind us.
Oh, okay, it's leaving.
But that is the ferry that
we're getting on that just left.
So we're getting the next ferry over
to the first island to start the race,
and where we're going to
begin the group cycling,
which is the first part.
And then we have challenges
on the subsequent islands
that we don't know yet.
So, we're going to be
figuring that out ourselves.
- So, the first island
is just going to be us
feeling things out.
So, we're just going to be
enjoying the beautiful view.
- Chilling with each
other, no competition.
Just a nice time.
- Just the boys hanging out.
(Garnt laughing)
- Boys on tour.
- [All] Boys on tour.
- We have bikes. If you
want to come have a look.
We have kitted these out,
it's like Pimp My Ride. Right?
We've got the battery charging the GoPro.
We've got helmets with GoPros.
We've got this thing
which carries our phone.
This is kitted out. This is 2020.
This is a fire hazard on wheels.
- Technology.
- We got walkie-talkies so
whenever we're not in view,
we can still talk with each other.
Sorry. I just realized you're
listening to this now, Nabby.
- Roger that, roger that.
- [Nabby] Yeah, I heard that, Garnt.
(all laughing)
- Totally legal in Japan, by the way.
Just saying, I'm joking.
(Connor chuckles)
All right, I guess we're ready to go?
- All right
- All right.
- Let's get going.
- Let's go.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)
- [Joey] Here's how the route works,
The Shimanami Kaido is
made up of seven islands
connected via bridges
with an easy route shown
in solid blue,
a hard route shown in the dotted line
and a partial ferry route shown in red.
Most locals recommend that
newbies split the route
into two or three days,
but we were going to do it in one day.
- All right, so we're at
the first part of the,
- I just want to use
the walkie-talkie, man.
This is so much fun.
- We are literally two
meters from each other.
- We just got off the ferry,
that's just over there.
And this is the first leg of the race
where we're going to be together.
So, we're just going to have like,
a leisurely stroll for the first part.
- We're going to test the waters, right?
We're going to see what's ahead of us.
(Connor laughs)
- I nearly fell.
- Oh my God, what a good
start. What a good start.
- So we just follow the
blue line on the road.
That's all we have to do the whole,
- Blue line right there.
- Race, you can see it on the
floor, the epic blue line.
- [Joey] The epic blue line.
- [Connor] That is going to be a guardian,
our savior today. Our shepherd.
- All right.
Well let's just go.
- Good luck.
- Jump right into it. Bye.
- 8:40. Let's go.
- Let's go boys. Woo!
- Oh shit. I didn't see
the blue arrows over there.
- Yeah. Look out for the blue arrows.
- This is already like, so confusing.
Is it recording? Whoa.
- [Garnt] This was it, the
start of our challenge.
The first island would
just be leisurely ride.
No challenge. No pressure.
There was little we could do to fuck up.
- I think we just ran a red light.
- Breaking traffic laws already
and it's on camera. Shit.
You good?
- Yeah. My GoPro keeps moving.
- Joey's already fucked something up.
- Come on, Joey. Seriously? Seriously?
- Let's go.
- Well, fuck you, guys. I'm out.
(Joey chuckles)
Let's go.
All right, We are on right now.
On our way to Enoshima,
which is the second island.
It's really scary though,
because we're right next to
a bunch of these tractors
and whatnot, oh God.
I'm going to slide on
through. Thank you, sir.
- See now, I'm not used to cycling at all.
And these cycle paths are pretty narrow.
We're right next to where
any cars could just hit us.
Luckily this isn't Southeast Asia,
where it's a free-for-all.
- Is it bad that my legs already hurt?
- I'm right there with you, Joey.
I am not looking forward to today.
- It's nice though, I
love being on a bicycle.
It feels good.
- My dick is itchy. Don't
know what that's about.
I will fix that.
- This is meant to be the leisurely part,
I don't know what's coming up next.
- So far the blue line
is just on the road.
Straight ahead, as you can see.
My pants are falling off.
- [Garnt] Woo, nice ass there, Joey.
(Garnt laughs)
Looking dummy thick for my angle.
- Look away. Don't point
the Gopro at my pants.
(Joey laughs)
- It's such a beautiful
countryside in Japan.
It's just so nice. It's so relaxing
We shouldn't forget that
this was a marathon,
not a race.
We had all day and, well, the
early signs weren't great.
- Hey, how you doing, Luke?
- [Luke] How's it going?
- I'm doing well. How's the driving going?
- [Luke] It's nice, its very,
My legs are pretty sore.
(Connor laughs)
Did you hear that Joey
said he's already tired.
- [Luke] Yeah.
(Connor laughs)
How are you doing?
- It's a little chilly.
My nips are a little perky
but I think we'll be fine.
There are like no cars on this road.
- [Luke] Hey Garnt.
- God, I'm regretting this already.
Is it bad that my legs are
already like burning a bit?
And my ass hurts so much already.
The padding does nothing. I swear to God.
- And my legs are getting
a slight bit tired already,
which is a little worrying.
- Yeah, same here.
Is anyone's ass fucking
rock hard right now.
(Joey laughs)
(Cars whizz past)
- [Connor] Oh, what's up?
- Oh, look at that dog. Look
at the dog. Look at the dog.
Oh, come here.
Let me chase the dog. I want
to get a shot of the dog. No.
- [Garnt] Luckily, we had
already been cycling for a while.
Have we been cycling for 20 minutes?
- 10 minutes.
- Fuck my life.
(Luke laughs)
- Watch out for the car.
- [Man] I know, I know.
- Is it my ass that's rock hard
or is it this seat that's rock hard?
Probably just not going to be
able to walk after this day.
Am I?
- How're you doing, Garnt?
- Not optimal.
- You kind of prefer the
drifting video so far.
- This is like that meme of
when Garnt realized he was
in a club and then the
sudden realization of;
Shit, I could be watching anime right now.
(Joey chuckles)
Damn, that water looks lovely.
- I hope there's an elevator.
But I have a feeling there
isn't going to be an elevator.
- [Garnt] With us already struggling,
some locals were kind enough
to show us how it was done.
- Oh my God. This guy's showing us up.
He's styling on us.
- Stop flexing.
- God, I wish I was him.
- Wait, are you sure
this is the right way?
- I think so. Yeah, the blue line's here.
- Oh, is it? Okay.
- We follow the damn blue line.
- [Joey] Nearing the
end of the first island,
we would encounter our
first of many challenges.
An uphill climb.
Oh cool. A 3% incline
for a kilometer, amazing.
- Oh. Oh, God.
Kill me now, please.
- I've got to rest my legs. Fuck that.
- God. I wish that was me right now.
- I just wanted to take a jaunty stroll
just to show the audience
the beautiful scenery, over.
- Meanwhile, I'm staring at Garnt's crack.
- That's the best view, arguably, over.
- You get to see the best hills, over.
- Why didn't we choose the electric bikes?
- I don't know. We should have.
- If humans wanted to do this,
they would have just never invented cars.
They would have never
fucking tamed the horse.
- We would have to climb a hill
every time we cross an island.
We were tired
and we hadn't even finished
the first bridge yet.
(Garnt sighs)
- A flat road. It's flat.
- Speeded up a little bit.
- At least I got here before Joey.
- Where are you guys?
Can you hear me? Over.
- Yeah, I'm at the beginning
of the bridge, over.
- I'm just going onto
the bridge as well, over.
- I can see you, over.
- Oh. Oh, you're not
too far behind me, nice.
Holy fuck.
(motorcycle engine revving)
I've never been jealous of
an old woman in my life.
That old woman on the moped.
- It is a little more beautiful
than how I feel right now.
I'll tell you that.
- This bridge is so long and vast.
- I love how you can actually
see the traffic as well
as it's driving past.
You can see the shadows. That's very neat.
- As an idea it sounds great,
Oh, yeah. Let's just cycle
70 to 100 kilometers.
Document our efforts, make
a YouTube video about it.
What a brilliant idea. What
a brilliant fucking idea.
- It is free for bicycles. Lovely.
- It's 50 Yen.
But it's not like there's any
way to prove that I did it.
- [Garnt] Thankfully, what
goes up must come down.
- Oh fucking lovely.
We've got a downhill
for about a kilometer.
Oh. Oh, I love it.
- Hell yeah. Woo.
♪ Deja Vu I just been
in this place before ♪
- Oh, isn't life great, Connor?
- I love this.
- Oh, drift king, drift king.
I'm using my drift skills right here,
that I learned in the last special.
- Oh, drift king. Hit the brakes.
- However, maybe I was
feeling a bit too good.
Oh my God. It's beautiful.
Look at the view.
- Oh shit.
(Garnt laughs)
- Did you get that on camera?
- Oh, there they are.
- Let's get it going, gamers. Woo!
- Oh my God. That nice breeze, holy shit
- [Garnt] Woo!
- Man, you really feel the
fucking wind resistance now.
(tire screeching)
Is that my tire? What is that noise?
I think I've got a flat tire.
- Oh no, we've got an injury.
- You got a flat tire?
- Yeah, it's making a
fucking horrible sound.
- All right. I'm right behind you.
- On brand, I had broken
something else on a special
and of course, the boys were
very, very understanding.
(Garnt laughing)
- Connor's broken another
thing on another special.
- How am I always breaking everything?
Oh, that's fucked. That tire is fucked.
- [Joey] Oh no.
- That's fucked.
- [Joey] That's actually fucked.
- When did you realize?
Was this on the hill?
- When we were going down,
I think I might have popped something.
because as I was going
down, all I heard was,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
- [Garnt] Really?
- Yeah.
That's bad, I can't even like cycle.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- At all.
Connor, the most expensive
thing on the set,
as Joey called him.
- How do you constantly
break shit in these specials?
How do you constantly do that?
- If we get you another bike,
are you just going to break it again?
So, how are you boys feeling?
- Not too bad.
- I think just it's painful
when you're doing it,
right now I'm not that tired.
- The padding is a lie.
- I don't know, it's kind
of helping. It still hurts.
- Every time I take my ass off the seat,
I can feel the blood
circulating again into my ass.
- I feel like my ass is
taking 10 dicks right now.
- My tire has popped, completely.
- [Man] What? Okay.
- And I guess we didn't plan for this.
- [Man] No. Are you off the bridge?
- Yeah. We're off the bridge on the road.
So, I'm thinking, why don't,
- [Man] We can come pick you up?
- Yeah, pick me up.
How did this break? Why has
the road got rocks on it?
(all laughing)
I have no idea why it broke.
- Stop having rocks.
- All right, see you, Connor.
- [Connor] Bye, boys.
- Have fun. How much
battery is left on the,
(bike crashes)
- [Garnt] Jesus.
- Fuck's sake.
- You're batteries just fell out too.
- Everything fell out.
- [Garnt] This boy.
- I can't get a W today, man.
- See you at the finish line, baby.
- I'm so fucking sad that
my thing fucked itself.
- And that was another
day in the life of C-dog
collateral damage VA.
- C-dog dog likes to break our shit VA.
♪ Why oh why did my fucking shit die ♪
- I can't believe he broke another thing.
What's he going to break next?
- Why is it the one dude who
always the most optimistic
about the challenge, ends up
fucking himself over somehow?
He broke two cars in the drifting video
and now he's just broken a bicycle,
not even one hour into the cycle.
This man is single handedly,
eating our budget alive.
And you know what the worst part is?
Connor had to break down
during the best part
of the fucking route,
AKA the downhill parts.
because of course he did.
- [Connor] While the
boys went off without me,
I needed to figure out
a way to fix my bike
and I don't really know how to do that.
Do you want to see how
fucked this tire is?
Look at that.
- [Man] Oh my god.
- Look how bad that is.
I actually really wanted to do that.
And we were on the nice bit as well.
We're on the home stretch.
Tell you what? Cycling up
that Hill was fucking pain.
Someone's mask is soaking.
All right, let's get it.
Let's get in, boys. Let's go.
You come up short. Very slowly.
(Connor chuckles)
Boys, can you hear me? Over.
- [Joey] I can hear you, over.
- Oh, we see you. We see you.
We're coming towards you now.
All right there they are, in front of us.
- Do you like this dummy thicc?
Ladies, join my OnlyFans.
- That wasn't very far at all. Was it?
Wait, where's
- Is this recording? Oh, fuck.
- So right now, we're
here on the map, right?
And the bike fixing place is down here.
- [Joey and Garnt] Oh shit.
- [Garnt] You're going on a journey.
- So I need to drive down
there, get my bike fixed
and then we'll come back probably up here.
And then based off, we're
going to do draws now, right?
So we have alternative routes.
There's the ferry boat, the hard route
- [Garnt] And the easy route.
- [Connor] Yeah, the normal route.
What we were going to do,
is one of us was going to take the boat.
One of us was going to
take the hard route.
And one of us was going
to take the easy route.
Now because we have a
clown within the group
who has up the entire schedule.
Connor is going to be taking the boat
because he has to basically,
- Get his shit fixed.
- Get his shit together.
So, what we're going to do is
we're going to have the race to see
who can get to the next checkpoint first.
- And this will determine the
points for the next challenge
and how difficult that will be.
- It's basically just going
to be between me and Joey
during the easy and hard route, isn't it?
- Well, the thing is, right?
So the ferry boat goes all
the way here to here, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] So, whoever's
going on the easy route
is going to eventually
go on the same route.
- So let's find out
which one of these boys
is doing the easy and hard.
I'm going to mix them up
- Give me the easy, please.
- I want the easy.
I'm so jealous of Connor
because I wanted the boat
because the boat's the
boat's the least effort.
- [Connor] I don't want to go on the boat
but it makes sense that
I have to go on the boat
because of schedule.
This is the boat that
I'm going to be taking.
- He's getting the easiest,
easiest routes by default
because he's a fucking clown.
- Clown dog VA.
- I have a piece of paper in each hand.
Let me mix them up again
just to make it real fair.
- Gacha gods, please.
(Garnt laughs)
- Who wants to Gacha
pool? Who wants to do it?
- I'll fucking do it.
- All right. Which one do you want, Garnt?
- I want the right one.
- Gacha gods, please.
Give me the easy route.
- Come on gamers, come on. No
- No.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Yes.
- [Connor] Joey's got the hard route.
- I almost couldn't jump
there because I was,
my legs are already jelly.
But we know who the
real loser is, that boy.
- I want to cycle, man. I want to go.
- I was saying, like along the route,
I love how Connor is always
the most enthusiastic
about these Trash Taste Specials
and yet he's always the one,
- That fucks it up.
- That himself fucks himself over. Fuck.
- Can this man take any more of that L's?
Find out on the next
episode of Trash Taste.
- We should clean that up.
(Garnt laughs)
- Which is happening is right now.
Now this is a straight up race.
No more leisurely cycling the park.
We've got to go full force now.
First part was a little
warm up with the boys.
A little nice session.
Now we've actually got
to separate ourselves
and go at it alone or a
nice car if you're me.
- I'm jealous, man. I
wish I popped a tire.
- I'm kind of happy
but I also kind of wanted the cycle, man
because the comments are going
to call me a fucking pussy.
- No, you're not a pussy.
You're just a clown.
- I'm just a clown.
- [Joey] The next part would
be a race across two islands.
Garnt had the easy route,
I had the hard route
and Connor would have
to get his bike fixed,
take the ferry across one island
and cycle the rest to the
checkpoint on the fourth island.
The routes would determine the placings
for the next challenge.
And only the two winners
would be allowed to enjoy the
refreshing Ekiben ice-cream
waiting for us at the halfway point.
- All right, give us a countdown
and we'll start this race.
- [Connor] All right. Three, two, one go.
Best of luck, boys.
- [Joey] Let's go. See
you in a bit, clown.
- All right. Let's fucking go.
(Joey singing in foreign language)
- While my roots was
advertised as the easy route,
I quickly realized that
might've been false advertising.
Oh no. And we starting
off with a fucking hill.
Of course we are.
(Garnt panting)
Did we get this mixed up?
Was this the hard route?
I think this might have
been the hard route
- This is a such a quiet town. Goddamn.
Guys are we sure we got the right thing
with the easy and hard route.
- Why do you say that? Over.
- This is not an easy route.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I don't know, man.
I'm having a jaunty
stroll over here, over.
- It's been nothing but hills for me.
Oh my fucking God.
- The Gacha gods are on my side, baby.
Garnt, is there any hills for you?
- [Garnt] I'm just trying to survive.
(Connor laughs)
- He's sounds like he's fucking dying.
- You okay, Garnt. How bad are the hills?
Are they really steep?
- [Garnt] I'm fucking dying, man.
(Joey laughs)
I immediately hit a super steep hill.
I'm going downhill now, thank God.
(Connor laughs)
- I'm glad you're already getting tired.
Hopefully the rest of it's easy for you.
- Well it looks like I lucked out, boys.
- It's a little stuffy
in this car, you know.
I weirdly wish I had the breeze
and the the hills blowing on me, over.
- You may win this race, Connor,
but you still took the biggest L, over.
(Garnt laughs)
- You having a nice drive, Connor?
- Garnt, I'm telling you, man it
honestly it's a little too comfortable.
I really wish I was breaking a sweat here.
- But I'm glad you're having
a good time, motherfucker.
Fuck you. Get out of my
face. Get out of my face.
I don't want to see
your face anymore, man.
(Connor laughing)
- It's a beautiful day,
Garnt. It's a beautiful day.
While the boys were busy
cycling their routes,
I was having a nice relaxing time
while my bike was getting fixed.
- By the way, if we stop for
sandwiches at some point,
Lawson's have tuna and egg sandwich.
It is my favorite. It is the
best sandwich at Lawson's.
There's no better
combination of egg and tuna.
So we're going to get
that changed over there.
And we've got about, I'd
argue about 10 minutes
to get this done. So we
need to be pretty fast.
Konichiwa.
(Connor laughs)
- That's so sweet of them.
I don't know why that warms my heart.
Normally, either people scurry
away when they see a camera,
but they were pretty pleasant about it.
I needed that. That's my power for today.
What is that? Is that fish in a can?
That's actually fish in a can.
All right so, here's my lunch today.
I have the ham sandwich from Family Mart.
Honestly, I think the Family
Mart sandwiches a meat,
but that's fine.
I went for a Pocari Sweat.
And I have a melonpan as
well, for extra sugar.
We however, were having
a less than pleasant.
Poor health. Oh God dammit.
- [Garnt] Guys, I'm dying right now.
- He's dying. I'm having a great lunch.
I'm having a ham sandwich with a melonpan.
- Fuck you, fuck you, fuck
you, fuck you, fuck you.
- Unfortunately, my nice lunch
may have come back to bite me.
So we've just arrived at the dock,
I'm going to just check the time
and we're looking at the schedule.
So it says Hiroshima,
which is where we are now,
there's two different boats.
There's one that comes at 11,
which goes to a different
place, which is Sawa,
and, it looks,
- Yeah, it says here, Sawa, 11:25.
See down there, right?
- Which one?
- Sawa, 11:25.
- [All] Sawa 11:25
- Yeah.
- I think that's,
- You know we are not on Sawa.
(computer shutting down)
We're in, yeah, Inoshima.
This is the one going backwards.
And this is the one going forward
and the one going forward we
just missed by 20 minutes.
Fuck, so that would mean,
if we hit the next one
it would be at 1:00 PM.
There's no way we can do that.
- So I had to improvise.
But the important thing
is the boys wouldn't know.
- I'll turn my location sharing off
so they can't see where I am.
So the boys don't know this
and we don't need to tell them
you can drop me off at the port.
I'm going to cycle.
Like I went on the boat.
They are going to think
that I went on the boat.
When this video goes live,
they see the first draft.
They'll be like, what the
fuck Connor, you drove?
Yes. I drove because we missed
the damn boat by 20 minutes.
We could have made that as well if we knew
we spent like 20 minutes
fucking around the family mall.
Fuck. I'm so dumb. All right, let's drive.
Fuck, I've skipped so much now.
- [Joey] While, Connor was
off on his bizarre adventure.
I had pulled way further ahead than Garnt.
So far in fact that I was
just enjoying my ride.
- Surprisingly not sweating maybe
because it's cold or it's chilly.
It's a chilly morning here in Hiroshima.
Mind you it's 11:00 AM on a Thursday.
People should be out
and about doing stuff.
What the fuck is that?
Did you see that?
Oh, I wonder if Connor
got the ferry on time.
Be interesting to see.
- I did make it at least as
far as the boys would know.
So we're pulling over real quickly now
to get this bike out of the boot.
I'm trying to be quick
because I want to catch up
because I don't want them
waiting for like 10 hours.
- [Luke] So what's our story?
- Oh your story's that you
dropped me off for the boat
and I'm on my way.
And my location services are
disabled because they broke.
- You got the 11:30.
- I got the 11:30 and
I'm coming down and my,
I'm blasting it down.
I said, I'm just going to go
ham then I'm holding back.
So they'll be like, "wow,
you got here fast didn't he?"
And I'll be like, "yeah, of course."
"I just want to catch up to my boys."
"Didn't I come on, come off."
"I didn't drive. No. Get
off it." Fuck me, dude.
I'm not looking forward to this.
See, you Gavis, I'm going very fast.
I am the speed right now.
I do not currently see the bridge
which is a little worrying.
I hope the boys don't figure
out I fucking cheated.
My bike is making a funny noise
which I won't lie is a
little bit concerning.
- [Joey] The Shimanami Kaido
is one of the most scenic
cycle routes you can find
in all of Japan
and in-between Al suffering
and Connor's improvisation.
We just had to find time
to appreciate the view.
(upbeat music)
- [Garnt] Can you see this?
God damn. Look at this water.
. Fuck, it's so beautiful.
Why is it so beautiful?
I love it.
- I'm fucking dying right now but man,
can't complain about the view.
- That is a beautiful beach.
I'm losing my shit over a beach.
I hate, I don't even like beaches.
- Oh my God. Look at that view.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh, what is this place?
I'm just cycling past the
temple here. Look at that.
- [Joey] The beautiful
view. The nice sea breeze.
This was meant to be a challenge
but I was having a great time.
- Sawa ikuchi Ikinajima. You
are a beautiful coastal town
and a beautiful coastal
island, port island
but it is farewell to
you island number three,
and we are onto island
number four, Omishima
where the first checkpoint
is going to be let's go.
The Roaring Dragon of Tatara Bridge.
Let's try to clap your hands here
then strange things will happen.
(Joey claps)
(clapping echoes)
- Holy shit.
(Joey claps)
That's so cool.
- I promise that after
this, I will be going
to the gym regularly. Woo.
You know, what's a weird flex.
I could honestly walk the rest of this way
to the checkpoint. And I
probably still get there first.
Maybe I am fitter than I thought I was.
Having accidentally been
given the hard route though.
I wasn't having a great time.
(Garnt panting)
- Come on Garnt. Imabari
40 kilometers. Let's go.
No problem.
I'm going to name my forty things I like,
anime titties, Sydney, my fiance,
orange juice, anime,
manga, ice cream. God I love ice cream.
You know what would be
great right now McFlurry.
- [Garnt] The Hill leading
up to the third bridge
would almost break me, and
it would get even worse
when I found out where Joey was.
- Anyone there?
- I can hear you. Over.
- I'm broken man. I'm
a broken man right now.
- Well, you probably
wouldn't like to hear then
that I've just arrived at the checkpoint.
- Fuck you.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'll be at, I'll be waiting
at the checkpoint for you boy.
- Fuck him. Fuck Joey. You know what?
Fuck listing off things I like,
how about listing off things I hate?
Joey for being an Australian dick head.
Who's fucking ahead of me right now.
Probably enjoying a nice fucking lunch.
(upbeat music)
Oh, I've got a second wind
now. Let's keep going.
Other things I hate Connor
for being so fucking smug
and thinking that this would be something
that we'd all want to do.
You know what happened today?
Someone destroyed the
fucking toilet in the Onsen.
So I couldn't even enjoy a
nice shit in the morning.
Now I'm complaining that I
can't even shit correctly.
Fuck nature. Fuck beauty. Fuck this ocean.
Fuck these mountains. Fuck Newton
and your fucking conservation laws
of the conservation of energy
or whatever that fucking thing is.
Why can't energy just be created?
Why can't I just not create the energy
out of thin air right now to put me
across the fucking bridge.
- [Connor] Garnt wasn't the only one
having a hard time though.
Well fuck, I've gone
the wrong fucking way.
I guess that serves me
right for cheating. Right?
That's my punishment for
being a dirty little cheater.
I've gone so far out unnecessarily.
You know what I didn't
realized on the road.
It says the place where we started
that I was cycling towards
and I'm cycling away.
So I probably just cycled an
extra three, four kilometers
the wrong fucking way.
Like a fucking monkey.
- Could be at home, chilling,
watching some anime,
playing some video games
but no, we had to go on a
fucking boys' trip and go cycling
because I've done that in my life so far.
I love exercise. Garnt feels
like watching you suffer right?
What a great fucking idea.
Chess. I can do that easy,
easy win against Connor.
No fucking problem, drifting,
what's the worst that
can happen in drifting
fucking rollover, crash and die.
But who the fuck gives a
shit? I'll make great content.
Well, there's the bridge
again from a nicer angle.
I'm like every fucking vlogger
is looking at this right
now being like, Oh, look
at this amazing view.
- Oh my God, look at that view.
- Fuck this view. Fuck these
islands. Fuck the water.
Just give me some fucking
anime titties man.
Well, I'm looking at the map right now
Garnt is on the bridge, he's halfway.
So he should be coming around soon.
I'm enjoying a very
nice ice cream right now
it's apparently a type of Mandarin
that is only really grown in Ekime,
Ekime is known for its mandarins.
So this Mandarin ice cream
I'm having, fucking nice.
- But somehow my little
tantrum would get me through.
I apologize for that. I had
a bit of a breakdown there.
- That wasn't very monkly of me.
- Here he comes. Garnt's
made it everybody.
(Joey claps)
A round of applause, Garnt's made it.
All that was left now was
to wait for the last boy.
- All right. So 1.2 kilometers average 3%.
Let's do it boys. If these boys struggled,
I'm sure as hell not going
to, I won't allow it.
I'm too prideful.
- Well, it looks like we've
gotten a message from Connor.
- It looks like he's about to join us
and he's about to hit that hill.
- That hill. I don't know what you mean.
I mean, it was just a
regular Hill to us wasn't it?
it's nice perspective for me.
Man, that's a money shot eh?
What a beautiful fucking view.
God, I want to swim in it so bad.
I can't wait to have a fucking
beer and some ramen man.
Ah, I see the drone. I see the drone.
- I've never seen a person takes
so many Ls in one day, man.
- I wish I was in France
so I could just stop
at all these beautiful landmarks for you
and just take it all in but
unfortunately the boys are waiting for me.
- So while I'm waiting for Connor.
I finally got my ice cream guys.
This is all made it worth
it. All this suffering
for this one ice cream. It's
a pretty good ice cream.
Cheers.
It's been roughly two
hours since I saw him last.
Oh there he is. There he is.
- [Garnt] There he is. There's our boy.
(Joey laughs)
Yes, we've done it. We've
made it the first part,
I would like to now do my victory speech.
I'd like to thank my legs
and my ass for not giving up.
I would like to thank Pokari Sweat
for making a great energy drink.
I am tumbling towards the end
so I will hold onto the bars and break now
but at long last we would
finally be reunited.
- Oh, is that a brand
spanking new bike I see?
- They said that you couldn't change tires
you had to get a new bike.
- That's not fair. You just
upgraded your bike basically.
- Don't you think it looks the same?
- No, it looks way better.
- Yeah. It's like some slick and black.
- What do you mean like that
has anything to do with it.
- Boys are back together.
(upbeat music)
- [Connor] We were about halfway through
and we had a bit of time to reflect.
- Yeah the boys don't know
I've kind of cheated so far.
I mean, it's not really cheating
because I would have had to do,
I'm trying to justify to myself,
but hi Joe, you listening?
Good. Good. Can't hear me. Fantastic.
I think we have a few
more challenges up next
and we don't really know what they are.
Pretty confident that I can get a dub
in the next few challenges,
I took a pretty big L
being the last to arrive
here, which sucks.
But next one, we'll get the next one.
I'm feeling sure. I feel good. I'm ready.
All your boys looked dead,
I'm pretty sure I'm going to be fine.
What up squad? It's the
King. It's been good.
Just been having fun.
I'm just enjoying the
scenery more than anything.
Like yeah, of course. It's fucking tiring
because we've been what?
doing it for the past
three and a half hours now,
we have cycled about
35-36 kilometers I think,
we're about halfway. Yeah,
I just thought, Oh my God.
Every time I go onto that
bridge like this one as well,
but the other two included. It's just man.
The view from there just never gets old.
It's so fucking nice.
And there's all these like
little like weird quirky things
along the way that I just
happened to catch an eye.
And I'm like, what the hell is that?
So yeah, it's been good.
Second half was going to struggle a bit
but yeah I'm going to murder them.
(Joey chuckles)
- I want to die.
- [Joey] The fourth island was simple.
It would be a drag race
across a straight road
playing a game of cat and mouse.
We would start from the person who went
on the hardest route Garnt to
the least hardest route Connor
in one minute intervals.
If anyone was able to overtake someone
they would have to do 20 squats
on our already dead thighs.
So whatever you do, don't look back.
- All right Garnt goes
first, a minute and a half.
Three, two, one, go.
- [Connor] All right that's began.
- Oh fuck. Fuck me man.
Oh, this burns so much already.
- Do you reckon you can catch him?
- It's going to be hard. I
mean it's a minute and a half.
- I don't care if Joey passes me.
I just really hope Connor doesn't pass me.
- Three, two, one go.
You got this Joey.
Catch up to that scum. All
right now it's just me.
- Oh my ass hurts.
- You know what I don't want to see?
Connor's smug face as he passes me.
- Four, three, two, one and go.
Wish me luck you to get it.
We're going to get low for aerodynamics.
- Can we all just agree?
Just to get along we're friends, right?
- Well I'm already getting
tired. What the fuck?
- I think I can see you Garnt.
- Joey can see me. Oh God.
- Ah. I'm fucking dying.
- [Luke] Keep It going,
you're almost there.
Oh my God.
- [Luke] See you at the finish line.
- Oh God.
I can see Joey. He's so close.
No matter what mother nature
wants, you can't stop me.
- Oh my fucking God I fucking
see him, he's right there.
- Come On, catch up.
- Oh God. No.
- I can see them both.
- Hey Garnty poo.
(Garnt panting)
- No.
(Joey cheers)
Damn it, I was so close. Oh
wow. We're all really close.
- I would have killed you
if I had any more time.
- I think you can tell
the sheer difference
in tiredness right now.
- I was like fucking
making hill town mons.
I'm like all like the Japanese people
like that was like slacking
were just looking at
me and they were like,
"what the fuck is going on with that guy?"
So we're going to take
about a three hour break.
- I'm just going to take a
break for the rest of my life
and just never do this again.
- I'm so sad. I did
such, I'd three minutes,
and I basically caught up to Garnt
with a three minute headstart.
- Yeah. Mind you though. You cycled what?
Like a quarter of what we cycled.
- You had an hour break. I
don't want to hear it, man.
You had plenty of break Joey.
(upbeat music)
- Right now, we did
the cat and mouse race,
which I fucking lost.
- Which was the worst idea
we could've had.
- Lost by this much.
- Garnt almost died.
- I just want to get through this day now.
- The producers have all
final challenge for us today.
For the final stretch of the competition,
we need to figure out what it is.
- Time trial.
- That's just a race with extra steps.
- It's a race with attitude.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- If that was a hundred meter
dash, this is like a marathon.
- Try our best to enjoy ourselves
for these remaining two islands.
- Let's just have fun guys
because I am having fun right now.
Can you see how much
fun I'm fucking having?
♪ F is for fuck ♪
I'm having a great time
even though I'm losing.
- Let's just jump right into it.
- Jump right into
- Let's jump off a cliff
- Now for the whole journey so far,
we've been able to live track each other
but we've all turned it off now.
So none of us will know where we are.
The only way we can figure it out
is if someone wants to reply to the radio.
So I'll just be like Garnt sucks penis,
there's a radio over there.
And if he wants to reply, he can.
Or if I'm right behind
Garnt, I can just pretend
that I am and be like, I see you Garnt.
- [Joey] over the final
and longest island,
we would be doing a time trial.
We would be going at five minute intervals
meeting up at the viewpoint
before the final bridge.
The winner would have the fastest time
and the losers would have to
do one squat for every minute
they arrived after that.
We needed to make the last
checkpoint before 4:00 PM
to see the final bridge before sunset.
Failure was not an option.
- Okay. Starting now.
Oh God. I'm already not good.
(Garnt groans)
(Garnt cheers)
- So yes. The question is
when will Connor and Joey pass me?
and will it's be, will I
be, how can I phrase this?
- Five, four, three, two, one. Go.
- All right. See ya.
- Good luck.
- This was it.
The final stretch,
running almost on empty.
I would immediately fuck up.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Fuck I went the wrong way
immediately. Oh my God.
- Let's go.
- [Garnt] Of course the
boys would let me take this
cock-up gracefully.
- I don't how Garnt missed the turn
it was pretty fucking obvious.
- Today on this episode of Bottom Gear,
Garnt doesn't know, right to left.
Connor brakes another vehicle,
don't test me Garnt, I'll
do it. Think about it Garnt.
If your bike breaks, you
get to go in the car.
- Can I just break my bike right now or?
- I'm pulling my bike off the cliff.
I don't know about you boys.
- I was tired of taking
L's on all the challenges
and this time I knew it
was my time to shine.
Joey!
(Connor laughs)
- Don't talk to me.
(Connor boom beating)
- Perhaps we could high five.
We're so close to each other.
I need to go get Garnt.
- Well then yeah, go get Garnt.
He's probably not even on the bridge yet.
Am I mad that he passed
me? No, because unlike him
I actually bike rode the whole way.
(Garnt panting)
What a view,
but fuck this view.
- [Connor] And it
wouldn't just stop there.
Guess who can see you.
- Oh my God, who's that behind me?
- I see you too Garnt.
- Oh shit. Oh no.
They already fucking see
me. What the fuck? Oh, God.
- Garnt where'd you go?
I was just starting to
have some fun damn it.
- Can't even fucking, hear,
understand Connor anymore.
Oh Shit. Oh fuck.
(Connor laughs)
What happened?
- Gear, my chain.
(Connor laughing)
Fuck you Garnt.
- Oh shit. Eric caught, what happened?
- Chain got unhinged.
- Oh shit.
- [Garnt] It was done. I had broken down.
My chain was stuck.
I didn't even know if I could
make the meeting point in time
and worst of all, I would have to deal
with Connor's smug face.
It all looked lost, but then
Joey hatched a cunning plan.
- Can you come and pick Garnt and I up
and drive us to the observation point.
(both laughing)
This boy talking so much shit
considering he was on a ferry
for half the fucking time.
Let's see how he likes it.
Some will say this is cheating.
Others will say it's, hits different.
Can't cheat if you're just smart.
The plan was simple.
We drive past Connor to give
Garnt a chance to fix his bike.
And he'd be none the wiser.
The only challenge was making him think
we were still behind him.
I mean Connor was the one who was like,
let's turn off the GPSes. All right, bro.
We'll play to your game.
(Joey laughs)
To be fair, the man was on
a ferry for half the time.
All right. We're just leveling
the playing field right now?
- Stop making excuses, I
don't feel guilty at all.
(Joey laughs)
Let's say you want to
say I'm cheating. Yeah.
I'm fucking cheating. Fuck you Connor.
- Please slow down
Connor. Let us catch up.
- Yeah, that's what I'm doing now.
- No fuck you, Go ahead. We'll catch up.
- No it's okay. I'll wait for you guys.
- Little does he know, Oh,
we're going to catch up
all right.
- Where all you boys.
The bottom of the Hill.
- No, don't worry, man. Just go ahead.
- [Connor] Where are you at?
- We Like literally just
got onto the island.
- Wait you just came off the bridge?
- Yeah, we just came off the bridge,
but we were hanging back.
Well, I was hanging back to
help Garnt with his chain.
- Out of fairness to the boys.
I will wait because what's
the point in winning.
If I can't talk shit to them on the radio
I want them to be close
enough that I can talk smack.
- [Garnt] Connor was none the wiser.
He was waiting on the bridge
as we had told him to,
because we were all going
to get a drone shot.
But of course he was
in for a big surprise.
- There was a big
fucking spider over here.
Let me get this GoPro one sec
and show you how gargantuan this boy is.
- I'm going to ask Connor.
If he can go onto the bridge,
for a drone shot now.
- Okay.
- All right the boys want
drone shots sun down.
- [Luke] So you put in this a little,
behind this bush on my right.
- Oh my God there he is.
- Are you moving now Connor.
- Yes I am moving now.
- All right okay.
- [Garnt] Hey Connor, hey!
- Hey Connor, hey!
- I waited for Garnt and
he fucking scammed me.
Are you kidding me?
- He probably still thinks
that I'm at the bottom. Yeah.
- Yo Connor. I just got
to the bottom of the hill.
So I'm coming up now.
- I'm on the bridge right now.
But come on, come on the bridge.
(Garnt and joey laughing)
How far am I supposed to go
on the bridge by the way?
- All the way to the end motherfucker.
I'll see you on the other side.
- We aren't doing drone shots?
(Garnt laughing)
- Me and Joey are in the car right now.
So you have fun cycling.
- I always knew you were weak
Garnt I knew it from birth.
They had cheated. The audacity.
I couldn't believe it.
- Fuck Garnt, man. Fuck Garnt.
He's already giggling in the
car. Having a great time.
(Garnt laughing)
- He was just like
(Joey disgruntles)
- Yeah, sure. I was, but
fuck me. Don't talk about me.
Focus on Garnt. He's the
one cheating. Broke my bike,
yeah, whatever dude. Like I broke my bike.
Okay. Garnt. Come on.
- [Garnt] We were cheating.
We fully admit it.
But considering that Connor
had skipped an entire island a bit earlier
we decided to level the playing field
and have a tiny bit of a headstart.
- So yes, we have just
magically teleported
in front of Connor.
I don't even know if he knows
that we are still in the race.
He will know soon enough though.
Yeah. He will know when
he sees us magically
at the observatory.
If we passed him and he was still like,
guys there's still a drone
shot going on. Right?
Guys it's happening,
where's my drone shot.
So we didn't want to fully cheat though.
We're about, I'd say five kilometers.
We're still going to complete the race.
- Yeah. We're about five
kilometers from the end.
- All right. And we off boys.
- [Luke] Bye.
- Bye, I just turn right here. Right?
- [Luke] Yes.
- Even having gone ahead,
we still had one final hill to climb
and oh boy, was this the
final boss of all hills.
- So it seems like my issue before
was that my gears were broken.
So anytime I put up the seventh gear
which is the highest gear,
the chain disconnects.
- This is so bullshit.
- It's literally been
uphill for like 30 minutes.
How can it do that? How did hills do that?
Who made hills man? That's fucked up.
They should never be
allowed to have that many
consecutive hills.
- Oh my God, dude. Look at this hill.
This is actually one of the biggest hills.
Like the steepest.
- Well, every hill must go down
I guess that's true in life.
I'm pretty far ahead to the point where
I can just chill. I can
just walk this baby up.
- [Luke] Hey?
- how's it going?
- [Luke] Want an update.
- What's up.
- [Luke] Joey and Garnt
are ahead of you now.
- What?
- [Luke] Yes.
- Why?
- [Luke] Garnt had an
accident with his bike?
It's a little bit broke.
- What's Joey's excuse.
Joey's one of the go in the
car. Are you kidding me?
- [Luke] So they are about
10, 15 minutes ahead of you.
So you've still got a chance.
- Are you fucking kidding me?
We all know that I won legit, but
- I mean they still don't
know about the whole scandal.
- Shh, Don't remember that.
We'll talk about that later.
- We should have used the car
for this one hill part, man.
Fuck the rest of it.
- That's exactly what I was thinking, man.
- Man, there's no way
maybe I can catch up.
I'm going to try my best to
kill these fucking jokes.
- [Luke] Hey Connor.
- This thing's cocking me. I want to go.
This better all be
straight. Mark my words.
- It's like that point
where you think you defeat
the final boss
but you've realized he has
three more health bars.
Jesus Christ man.
- It's just pain. There's
no enjoyment anymore.
- So We have gotten to the final points
of this race of the time trial.
And I would like to post a time
of one hour and 31 minutes.
Now that's that's a
pretty solid time I think.
But Joey has got an even better time.
- Yeah, I have actually broken
the one minute, ah one minute
one hour and 30 minute barrier
with one hour and 29 minutes,
18 seconds. Damn dude.
- And now all that we have to wait for
is to see what Connor's time is.
- Yeah. I'm curious. I'm curious.
- I'm curious as well.
- What do you think,
you think he's going to
come under two hours?
- Let's hope so.
- I don't want to wait here for too long.
I mean he's so slow. Like
why is he so slow? Jesus man.
Hey Connor, are you in range yet?
- Yeah, I am cheater. What's up?
- Oh, he's in range. Oh,
how are you doing man?
- As an honorable man.
I'm happy with my choice.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- How fucking far ahead
did you go? Jesus Christ.
- We just went a bit
further than the bridge man.
- That's bullshit. You probably
went half the fucking island
you're shouting out your ass.
- No, no. What are you talking about, man?
- You're all losers at the end of the day.
- Anyway, we've posted our times.
We are just waiting for your time now.
- What's your excuse
Joey? Garnt's chain broke.
What's yours Joey?
- I'm tired.
- pieces of fucking shit.
I'm tired of waiting.
Fuck you Garnt.
- If we didn't have this,
it would just be like
three silent cyclists
just talking to themselves
this entire time.
It's just, it's just like
watching three jaywalks at once.
(Garnt laughs)
I know, right?
- All right. Hopefully I can
get a little bit up this hill.
More than I would by walking.
I said 3.4 kilometers for
fuck sake. That's ridiculous.
Oh, look at them. Smug.
Look how smug they are.
- You made it.
- Well, look, who's not riding his bike.
- Look, you cheated Garnt.
I got here on my own.
Do you know how that feels Garnt?
- Do you know how that feels
Mr.
I-took-a-fucking-cruise-across-two-fucking-islands?
- Yes I did. And it was
wonderful, thank you very much.
- I had a nice leisurely drive.
- I did not have a
choice in that decision.
- You chose to bend the
rules. That was your call.
- How do you want to end this video?
- I think about that right
now. I've been cycling.
I don't know if you've done it.
- Yeah, we did actually. First half
- First half?
Let me guess, you to skipped
the like four kilometers hill.
- I have no idea what
you're talking about.
- Yeah, yeah, you don't
because you skipped it.
You would know if you
went through that pain.
- We went through this pain.
- Oh this is nothing compared
to what it was earlier.
- Sounds like a you issue.
- Yeah. I don't know, man.
Those first two islands were pretty tough.
Not going to lie.
- I mean, you have no proof
that you can show us now
that it was like a hard hill. So you know.
- you can watch my, you can see me dying.
- I don't watch Trash Taste videos.
- I'll just skip Connor's
parts. I don't watch it for you.
Control left Garnt in the chat
(Joey laughing)
to be like, who's talking about me.
All right. I don't give a shit about you.
- Wow. That's awful.
- So what was your time, dude?
- What did you time?
- What was my time?
Well, are we count factoring
in the cheating or?
- No, no, no. countering in--
(crosstalk)
what is your time?
1:43;43.
- 1:43 so
- Really, you're going to count the car?
Look at Joey. Joey hasn't
got a sweat on him.
He hasn't fucking done anything.
- Okay. In the rules, it
said time trial, right?
It said, this is the time to
get to the ending checkpoint.
- On your bike.
(crosstalk)
This is a bike challenge.
- Let me get the paper.
- It didn't say on the bike.
It said to get to the checkpoints.
- It's Okay.
I'll take solace in the fact
that I got a forfeit win.
I just thought the way I
wanted to win, you know
I crushed you easily,
you know, overtook you
in five minutes.
When you had four minutes ahead of me gone
that must've been humiliating.
- Even when he thinks he's got the W
just ultimately he got the L.
- what do you think
chap? What do you think?
- Yeah, what do you think?
- Because I will say, at least
we completed on the bikes
that we started with.
(Joey laughs)
It's not my fault if my bike broke,
- Hey, my bike broke and it's still here.
What your chain fell off?
That's not broke Garnt.
- Hey man, whatever, I just
find the way. I persevere.
- [Garnt] Physically exhausted.
And the point system
now, far out the window
we had made it three
unfit weebs on their bikes
with a little bit of assistance.
And we were rewarded
with the stunning view
of the final bridge to the final island.
- I'm just going to say it.
Even these stairs are like,
- Yeah, they hurt, they hurt to go up.
- Look at these piddly little stairs.
- Oh fantastic.
- Oh God. Up more stairs.
(upbeat music)
- So guys, we made it.
- We did indeed make it.
- I'm not sure
(Joey chuckles)
- Is that the last bridge?
- That's the last bridge.
- That is the last bridge.
- Oh shit.
- It's also glorious.
- [Joey] And then that
is the main land Ehime
right over there.
- Final thoughts?
- Well, I mean, saw it on a cycle
So I'm kind of not too
excited really If I'm honest.
- I think though we should do
this last stretch together.
- Yeah.
- Like good friends do.
- If we must. If we must.
- Shall we boys? Shall we?
- Considering you've ruined
the sanctity of the sport.
What's the point of competing anymore?
It doesn't mean shit anymore.
- We're all just friends.
- Let's just get home.
- And I want to, I want to
rest, Onsen, a beer and cry.
- At the same time.
I'm up for doing this last stretch.
So you see this bridge, it's a metaphor.
- Oh my God.
(Joey laughs)
Shut up Garnt.
- Before we crossed the bridge
we might just be, you
know, normal, you know
normal anime nerds or tacus,
whatever you want to call us.
But after we crossed the
bridge we will be invigorated.
We would have achieved something
that I'm just talking shit.
Rage Shadow Legend sponsorship
script. What is this shit?
(Garnt laughs)
- [Connor] We had cycled to
one of the most beautiful
landscapes you can find in all of Japan.
And there was little we could
do, but Marvel at its beauty.
(Connor burps)
- [Joey] very nice.
- [Joey] Tired, battered and broken.
We had one final hurdle to overcome;
the Kurushima Kaikyo bridge,
not just the longest bridge on the route,
but one of the longest
bridges in all of Japan.
Four kilometers of pure bridge
and yet another hill to climb.
The only solace we had, was
we were suffering as much
as each other.
- Here we go.
- All right, let's go.
- Oh my ass hurts.
- My ass hurts so much.
- Can't sit down.
(Joey grunts)
- Is this what hemorrhoids feels like?
- I genuinely think I
have AIDS or hemorrhoids.
- I'm feeling like my legs are
just making battery acid now.
- Ow, Ow, Ow.
- What are we doing here?
Just to suffer again.
- Ow, ow, ow. I want to cry.
- Why do cyclists do this?
- I don't know. Why do
they think this is fun?
- People legit do this for fun.
- People do this off camera un-ironically.
Imagine doing this not for content.
- I hate my life so much right now.
- I can't guys, I can't.
- I need a break.
- I can't fucking do this anymore.
- Oh, my ass.
- we're waiting for you.
- Come on. You can do it.
- Go, take the lead.
(Joey panting)
- You okay?
- Yeah.
- Oh no.
- I'm going to wait at the top.
- Okay. I'll walk with you Garnt.
- [Garnt] Like how many
more things can you break?
I thought my spirit was
broken five hours ago.
- [Joey] My mind, my mental
and soon enough my ligaments
are going to break.
Now. I truly understand the
hand-tied tag Mind break.
(Joey laughing)
- [Joey] We've been doing this all day.
- [Garnt] I know.
- [Joey] I could have
been to the entire anime
during this time.
- We've been doing it
basically since we woke up.
Morning till night.
- I'm not even talking. I'm just so tired.
I just,
I just want it to end. I
want the suffering to end.
- [Luke] We've got the drone behind you.
- Wait, really? Oh yeah,
we see it all right.
Whoa. God, God, God.
- My legs just gave up there for a second.
Take it nice and slow.
(Garnt singing)
(Joey and Connor sing)
- I can't even talk anymore.
(Connor burps)
Slow down. No need to worry.
No, no, no, no. I insist.
- I'll do it myself.
- Going over the bumps hurts so much.
- Ow.
- Any bumps. Right?
- I think just like the sheer willpower
has just like numbed my legs and butt.
- [Garnt] Yeah,
- And I just don't feel anything anymore.
- I feel like this day may
have given me a permanent fear
of hills and just slight inclines.
- Is there another fucking bridge?
- I think so.
- Oh my God. No way.
- Why am I here?
Just to suffer, just to fucking cry,
that ain't right, man.
That ain't right.
- Oh my God. The moment my ass
lifts off the chair is like
the most excruciating pain
- Just plant in that man, don't move it.
- Where's the stop point.
Tell me so I can stop this last time
and I'll never start again.
(Garnt groans)
- Fuck.
- Thank you for warning me
Garnt. Now I know that's there.
- Pretty dark. I can barely see anything.
The lights, they do nothing.
- And I'm sure their
GoPros can only see my face
but it is very dark.
Wow. That got dark fast.
- Cycling tunnel to the left.
- I see the finish line.
- Look at that.
Look at how beautiful that looks.
(Joey joyfully shouts)
Let's go.
- Oh my God, I'm in such pain.
I've got fucking arthritis for sure bro.
- Fuck yeah, boys.
- Going on the site, it was so good.
- Oh fucking hell Garnt, you've
got shit all over your hand.
(Garnt laughs)
All right. We're finally,
finally fucking done.
- Game is we are done.
- That bridge was so long.
- I am broken physically,
mentally, spiritually.
- My ligaments are probably broken.
- You know like every
anime when they get punched
hard enough, they cough up blood?
I feel like I just want to do
(Joey coughs)
Just cough up blood every second.
I'm on the fucking hill like
(Connor coughs)
but I got to keep fighting
for the Leaf village.
- But this is the cycling terminal
which means that we Trash Taste Boys
have officially completed
the Shimanami Kaido trail.
I like attempted to muster
up some happy feelings there.
I was like
- You know I mean, I wouldn't be happy too
if I didn't do it all. You know?
I mean, I'm just saying, if I cheated.
- Someone went on a ferry
- Not my fucking choice, I had to go.
You fucking say that.
- You must blame the
Gacha gods for that one.
- It was kind of your fault
that you have to go ferry.
- Yeah. You're the one
that popped the tire.
- We're never going to
hear the end of this.
- And we'll cut back to
the studio now anyway.
Yeah. All right.
So we'll cut to when we're not dead.
Yeah. All right?
- [All] Bye.
- Boys I have to ask one question.
How does it feel to be a
cheater? A dirty little cheater?
- I feel good. I feel great.
Actually, I feel shit.
That was the hardest
challenge I've done in my life
probably.
- Can we please make the next one
not physically like suffering?
- I want to suffer for the videos.
- No. I really don't.
- I thought it was okay
suffering as a thought,
but then I did it and halfway through,
I wanted to end my life. I
want it to be it to be over.
I was fine cheating. And you know what?
I, you know, I was going
back looking through it.
I think we kind of cycled
around the same distance.
So that makes me feel all right.
- Yeah we leveled the playing field.
- I had no choice.
(everyone laughs)
You guys chose to ruin
the sanctity of our race.
I couldn't believe it.
I actually ran the numbers boys,
because I was that determined
that I went through all
the footage to check.
Turns out, even if I
didn't break for 30 minutes
and you still cheated,
I actually still would
have beat you on the time.
- You were that desperate for a W?
- That's how desperate I was for a w
- Why would you assume
there was any sanctity.
(all laughing)
This is Trash Taste.
- I won't forget this
on the next special boy.
- Maybe don't break a bike next time
and you can play by the rules.
- If you play fast and
loose like I do Garnt,
sometimes things get broken.
(Joey laughs)
- But yeah.
How would you boys feel about
completing the challenge?
I mean, I feel like, you
know, I skipped a fair bit
but I still feel happy
that I actually did it.
- Yeah. It feels good
being the real winner.
You know, that's what I want to say.
- Finally, become the winner
of a Trash Taste Special.
- So any final thoughts
on the challenge itself?
- I would really liked to do
that again without cameras
and be able to do it at my own pace.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I want to do that in
more than a single day.
I want to spread out over multiple days.
- Oh no, it's fine. Come on.
- No, it's not fine. It's not.
- It's fine. It's fine. If
you can do that in one day.
- You know I want to do, actually
I want to go on the ferry.
- Like we never figured
out what it was like
to be on the ferry.
- This was the perfect time
for us to have a beach episode
and we were just suffering
the entire time. I'm salty.
Where's our beach episode.
- That's our next special
- that's our next special the beach.
There's no challenge.
Just the beach episodes, but yes.
- I bet Chris would come to that one.
- Yeah definitely.
- Yeah. I want to give a quick
shout out to our Patreons
for allowing us to make
a challenge like this.
This was, as you can probably tell
a very expensive challenge
to do a lot of logistics
and it was way harder to
film than a drifting episode.
Wasn't it?
- Yeah. Well, when you're
spanning over a hundred kilometers
there's cars involved,
cameramen, it is a bit of a mess.
- There's Literally double the camera's,
double the staff like,
just double everything.
- Double rip my wallet.
So if you want to support
these episodes of Trash Taste
and we have so many more
ideas that are even more crazy
than this, and if you want
to get in and support that
please do consider going to our Patreon
and you'll get your name in the credits.
Get the quotes
- Like all these lovely
people, lovely Patreons
who watched us suffer for their money.
So thank you very much.
Fuck you but thank you.
(Connor laughs)
- And there are definitely more specials
and challenges to come.
So hopefully you guys
stick around as well.
- So I guess we'll see you guys soon
in the next Trash Take Special.
- Bye
- Bye.
(upbeat music)